good morning everybody it's uh Saturday
morning thanks for uh taking the time
out of your weekend yes
interesting weekend we got Fourth of
July holiday on Tuesday but it seems
like a lot of people are going to take
advantage of a long weekend and
um you know today sort of the the start
of it so again thanks for coming out to
get started in about uh 15 seconds or so
I'm going through some last minute
checks making sure the sound is okay and
everybody could hear me okay
so just bear with me and we'll get
started in a second
uh yeah happy fourth uh Maria it's
gonna be a nice long weekend uh-huh
you know it's it's
one of those things when a holiday comes
on a Tuesday I think people like to
start uh start a little bit early and
make a long long weekend out of it as
opposed to just the Monday holiday Simon
uh good evening yeah I know you're over
there in uh in Singapore thanks for
coming out and uh Chris good you can
hear me okay
um Maria I'm in I'm in Chicago area just
about uh 45 50 minutes outside of
downtown Chicago
uh oh Florida yeah Florida's nice
except for the mosquitoes and the
crocodiles
um
okay so yeah it looks like everything is
working fine so I'll just uh sort of
Jump Right In you know the the order
flows combo indicator uh for ninjatrader
eight is yeah it's a
it's an indicator that
you know we just recently actually had
it coded but it was something that
you know I've been using in my trading
for a long time it just never dawned on
me to have it coated and you know over
the last you know over the years I one
of the questions I get most is
um you know what's your favorite trade
setup and and the combo is actually
based off of one of my uh favorite trade
setups and you know it's
it combines a lot of aspects of order
flow let me get my slides going on here
it combines the point of control the
value area imbalances and price action
it doesn't uh it doesn't use Delta okay
I'll just say that up front
um
in this in this particular setup uh it's
sort of beltra sorry Delta
um I'll say delta neutral but it doesn't
use Delta in its analysis and really
it's trying to identify where spine
demand comes into the market which is
going to help Drive price away from the
balance area so you know before I jump
into the charts I just want to sort of
take you through some of the settings
you know for those of you that already
have the indicator
um some of these slides are going to
look familiar they're taken out of the
user guide but just really quick I just
want to run through that really you know
before I start jumping into the actual
charts
um you know just some of the the basic
requirements now you're going to need to
use tick replay and you know why is that
important is because if you're say you
know like here this is my chart what is
this this is a Swiss franc
um
you know one minute chart if you don't
have tick replay
right you're not going to see the the
signals on the historical chart or
you know what you will see is once the
market is open and it starts plotting
you'll get the signals but you just
won't see it on you know the previous
thing sometimes you know people don't
realize they don't have tick replay
enabled and if
you don't have it enabled then you're
not going to see anything showing up on
the historical charts although you would
see it once you open your chart and
going forward okay but you know a lot of
people like to throw the indicator up
and then you know sort of scroll back to
see you know how I performed but you're
not going to see anything if you don't
have uh tick replay
is not enabled so just make sure that
that's enabled excuse me
um just really quick some people you
know get sort of
stuck on tick replay like sometimes
um you know I know in the past you know
we got this new version of ninjatrader
that's out
um there's a setting under here Market
data under the tools uh you'll see it in
here under historical this is show Tick
replay so if you have that if that is
unchecked okay that's unchecked when you
like open up a chart or something
well let me get a new chart here because
that one's already fresh but if I were
to open a new chart
okay you're gonna see down here at the
bottom it doesn't have the enable tick
replay like this other chart does right
this one was open with it already right
now it's too late it's already changed
but if you if yours looks like that
where it's not letting you enable tick
replay just go to the options go to
tools go to options Market data under
properties under Market data show Tick
replay okay that will give you that
option there
so that when you have a chart right
it'll have that there right if I were to
open a new chart
right it's there okay so make sure
that's enabled you know that's just uh
you know something I something you know
maybe one out of
20 traders that are new to ninjatrader
sort of run into that uh issue
so make sure tick replay is enabled
um now the thing with the license token
okay now
the indicator's license per machine so
because it's linked to the unique uh
ninjatrader machine ID so if your
machine ID changes I don't need your
machine ID but if it changes then
if it changes because of a Windows
upgrade or bios upgrade just let me know
um that your machine ID that you just
had a Windows upgrade Etc then I could
just simply reset it if you are changing
PCS you know sometimes you know our PCS
die on us and you need to get a new pc
then you're going to install it again
then I would need to create a new
license token so
it's really simple just email me my good
order flows but what I suggest people do
is you know in the subject line put new
license token for overflows combo
um or something to that effect right or
or reset the license token for order
flows combo if you just need a reset uh
what
what slows things down is sometimes you
know I send out emails on on other
things
um and then people just reply to that
and
those tend not to get responded to
quickly because sometimes those get
filtered out right based based off of my
email settings so just you know it the
best way to do it is you know Mike at
order flow is just a reset license token
for order flows combo or can you know
new license token
right for order flows combo okay
um all right so let's take a look at the
settings really quick to sort of go
through your license token right when
you open up the indicator setting Okay
so
when it's on here okay
all you have to do right you go to order
flows combo you drop your license token
in here hit apply you only need to do
that one time you don't need to do that
every time you open up a chart anytime
you open up a new chart and you add it
on there you don't need to enter your
license token just one time okay let's
just bear that in mind and
um
that way you don't have to keep entering
it over and over and over again okay so
now the individual settings they're just
going to run through these I'm going to
show you on the charts you know the
adjustments you could make based off of
you know different types of markets how
they trade
um
enable swing filter and swing period go
together that's if you want to look for
swing highs or swing lows POC filter and
PLC strength these two are related
you'll notice a little check mark next
to POC filter that means it's enabled
default is enabled and it's set to two
which is your normal strength now there
are four levels you can set one two
three four
zero is not a level all you have to do
is uncheck it to disable it okay people
think that I could enter zero to disable
it just uncheck it
um
the lower you go the stronger it gets
okay so the lower you go the fewer
signals the higher you go you're gonna
get more signals if you have it disabled
you're going to get
a lot more signals obviously because
it's not taken into account the POC
now the value filter
and value strength again also related to
disable it just uncheck it right you
just click on there to uncheck it now
there are three strengths one two three
again you wouldn't enter zero and you're
not going to enter something like 10 or
anything like that just go one two three
three strength levels default is set to
one
which is basically the minimum balancing
value two is sort of the average and
three is the maximum okay
um now again on on certain markets like
slower moving markets maybe you want to
disable it like on some bonds and Grains
now the supply and demand filter
again uh there's a check mark next to it
default is enabled that's why there's a
check there to disable you just uncheck
it okay and this one also has three
strengths you're not going to enter zero
or the strength you just uncheck it okay
now again the default is one which is
normal two is a little bit stronger and
three is the strongest okay obviously if
you disable it it's not taking that into
account
now the next part is the momentum
strength now this one's got seven levels
this one doesn't have a enable or
disable to disable you'd enter zero okay
one through six
one is basically the first sign two is a
little bit more three and four or is
around you know normal momentum
obviously six is going to be your
strongest
um you don't set it above six but uh
cause some issues and so I'll just keep
it between one and six I keep it at four
most of the time
again difference between three and four
is small but you know on some markets it
does make a difference
um I would suggest either disable it or
maybe have it at one three or four or
six now there's a sound alert this
question came up in an email that I got
there is a sound alert
so to enable it you're just uh check the
box and then again you just go into your
wherever your program files are on your
PC
and choose which one you want and we
sort of have a default one set up
um just really quick if
what the folder looks like
you just click there right it's alert
one but as you see when you go into your
folders there's ninjatrader already has
some set up inside right so you just go
into your PC or ninjatrader under your
program files choose ninjatrader8
sound
folder there's alerts right the alert
one is the one you know what some people
do is sometimes they want to record a
sound and just put it in there maybe
they got a couple different indicators
going on and you know maybe they they
want to have a different alert for each
one so they'll say you know they record
a little sound file if you're going to
record a sound file keep it within
you know maybe two or three seconds you
don't have a long one because if it
keeps going off or something like that
it's a it's a problem but you want it
too short so you know people say like
order flows combo or something like that
but it's up to you I I just default this
set to alert one
all right so let's take a look at the
combo in action so again settings are
are fairly simple
um
you know well again this is a Swiss
franc let's look at uh we'll start with
I don't know euro currency first yeah I
like the currencies
um you know people you know when it
comes to start trading Futures you know
sort of the way that people come to the
Futures markets is they see other people
posting stuff on
Twitter on Facebook oh yeah I made you
know five thousand dollars on NQ today
you know oh I mean I should be trading
in queue there's other markets out there
that often follow order flow much better
than the stock indices
um currencies do nicely
um bonds do nicely uh you know I think
grains do but again you know this is
nothing glamorous about saying that you
you trade soy meal or something but you
know at the end of the day it basically
just comes down to
um you know what you're doing as a as a
Trader what you want to get out of the
markets all right so let's just uh add
it here
um from scratch and it'll go sort of
take a look at the charts with the
settings
um there's a few things I'm going to
talk about also like the trade entry
signal and the signal box uh the draw
modes right these people see the zones
and you know wonder how to trade around
those zones okay so what do we got here
so this is Euro currency now no no
signals with the default setting on
Friday there was surprisingly no signals
on on the one minute chart now there was
a little bit earlier in the morning uh
European time
um you know some nice
little moves down here again you know
from like the 108 sorry 109.0
203 area all the way down to you know
what was that well down to new lows then
you rallied up now you'll notice there's
these zones being drawn out okay some
people like to have these now it's even
though you see oftentimes right a market
can like come back right to a Zone like
right here
it's not something that
I particularly will trade you know I'm
not going to say oh I had some you know
a signal generated
up here and then let the market sell off
and come back up to that area that's an
area I'm going to get short
um really what I'm the way I use the
zones is once I see a Zone being drawn
out right like this and then it's not
tested immediately that's an area that I
like to lean on a bit more okay like
you know like like this one here or
these here these here now if you don't
want to use the zones what you can do is
you just go into the indicator setting
and where it says there's two ways you
could do it you're just uh change the
signal box width from five down to zero
I should disable it
and click ok so right no zones you still
have the signals there okay
um
another way to do it you know when when
we first released software years ago we
had as a fixed Zone and I would draw it
out five so if you were to change it
from fixed to five
from until tested back to fixed
change the signal box width in bars
that's how far it draws out
and you'll see sort of these smaller
zones being drawn right five price
levels or five bars starting from the
signal bar so one two three four five
the way I've always traded that I used
to use this when I was looking at
stacked imbalances back in the day is
because I'd be looking I got a signal
based on the order flow I'm looking for
the market to start move away from there
within five bars if after five bars it's
sort of trading back in there that's not
a signal that I'm I'm interested in
taking
so again you could use this the
zones right until tested or fixed or you
can disable them all together again to
disable it uh all you'd have to do
is just
changed you know it doesn't matter what
you have it on fixed or until tested all
you have to do is this signal box width
in bars change that to zero okay that
will disable
those zones completely me personally I I
just prefer to have it it's just
something there you know crutch maybe
um to give me a little bit uh
you know for me you know I find the
markets very visual you know I want to
know areas where the market is sort of
running away from okay now just really
quick another thing that I want to talk
about is the trade entry signal for
those of you that aren't familiar with
the trade entry signal we have it it's
its own setting inside here and its
default is enabled and you'll see
there's two settings in there there's
trade price level in ticks maximum you
can do it is five trade validity in bars
again Max minus five and default is set
to one and one
if what this means is basically okay you
have a
signal generated right
based off the order flow that's what the
zone is going to start drawing out like
telling you hey you know what there's
something happening here in the order
flow
pay attention now you don't see an
actual signal come out until
the bar completes and in this case
something else happens in the Oracle
that's why you don't see it right on the
next bar it's got something happening
starting to develop here in the order
flow on this bar that's why the zone is
drawn out then it's waiting for a bit of
confirmation here now it's waiting for
this bar to start forming and trade
lower
okay so you see this green bar obviously
we opened up lower let me make this
bigger
trade lower than this red bar so it's
telling me after completion of this red
bar this next bar moved at least one
tick from the low here of this bar
okay just like here right something
happened in the order flow you got the
confirmation then the market starts
moving down in this bar
that's why the signal is generated here
's another signal order flow is telling
you something bearish happening
next bar
okay sort of that confirmation however
there's no actual down triangle telling
you there's a short here because this
green candle didn't trade any lower if I
were to have this
disabled
trade entry signal disabled
foreign
now you're going to see the signal
actually come in on this bar signal
coming on this bar in this bar so now
you're getting you know the actual
signal here whereas before you weren't
okay so when people say well why do you
use that well
you could choose to use it you could
choose not to use it I use it because
I'm waiting for you know I still want
confirmation in the order flow I'm
willing to give up
this one trade here
right even though this one you know for
the most part worked out Market went
lower I've already got shorts above it
anyway but this trade here didn't work
out if I had the trade entry signal
disabled
okay I would get a signal a Buy Signal
here which
just honestly immediately failed but
failed within
um you know four or five bars that would
have stopped me out so
I I just find overall it just helps me
me personally
find let's say find better trades but
sort of eliminate those trades where I
don't get that follow-through order flow
because you know remember at the end of
the day it's not just about you
identifying something happening in the
market other people also have to be
buying or selling
you know in your direction because
you can identify something say oh this
is very you know this is very bullish
people say oh yeah I Gotta Buy you know
I can get in before everybody else but
if there's nobody else coming in
who's going to move the market up you
you buy your
two three four five contracts but then
nobody else is buying Market's not going
to go up because after you buy you're
done now you got to sit there and
hope that other people are identifying
something bullish taking place that are
they're also going to be buying
right but if I know that there's
something like here something bearish in
the market it sort of tips its hand and
say yeah there's still some more selling
okay I could get short here I could get
short here you know this one it took a a
bit of time for the market to sort of
manifest itself then make its move now
you could
adjust these settings out right normally
most of my indicators I use two and two
okay two ticks over the next two bars
this one we got it set a little bit
faster at one and one so it's just it's
not leaving much to the imagination
um if I were to set it to two and two
you know maybe there might be a few more
signals but again you could set it up to
five okay so it means
um you know five
and see if I set this to five right
trade price level and takes to five the
next bar would have to move five ticks
okay so I don't necessarily recommend
that but
you could
um you know if you were to keep it at
one and set the trade validity in bars
to five then it's telling you that the
Market's got to move in your direction
at least one tick over the next five
bars okay so now I got a signal here
right I still don't have a signal here
because the Market's not moving
in my direction down here it's starting
to so it does make a slight difference
however you want to change it
um you know you're seeing
a few more signals come in here uh later
in the day okay
so like here there was a signal it might
be a little bit hard to see it's kind of
small there was a bullish signal coming
in here
this bar sort of confirmation bar but
the market didn't go any higher
right and then it's sold off people say
well yeah yeah this nice move up but
yeah but at this point right if you're
getting long in here 108 95 and a half
pulls all the way back down to 91 I mean
I don't know where you're going to have
your stop
you know
people say well can you put your stop at
the Zone yeah you could
um you know if you that's one way people
use these zones so you have a little Buy
Signal here and obviously it comes back
down stops you out okay
so like again you know people they'll
use the zone
as well for stop placement so sort of
the other side of the zone so your stop
is going to be up here or up here up
here that's why I find these trades
that's why I like to have the zones
drawn out so that when they start to
when the market starts to move and it
just leaves these zones
um you know naked so to speak
it just you know you see them a lot on
very big moves
so currencies I find that the default
settings are
you know are good I mean this is the
default setting this is on I mean even
though those didn't catch anything on
the default you know on the on the one
minute chart here
yesterday until later in the day you had
a little sell-off here and you know a
couple other moves coming in here
um let me just set this back to the
default one and one here
you know even if you were to go down to
again not everybody
would want to do it but
I know some people that use like a 30
second chart
um you know you could use the default
settings on these
um you know on the currencies you know
there's some nice moves to be had on the
currencies
yesterday even the day before right in
the in the evening in the European
sessions in the evening session but you
know during Europe hours you get nice
movements on the currencies again this
is with the default settings
again you could adjust it I'll show you
how to adjust it in a second
yeah
buy right here at the High people say
well you gave me a buy up here at the
high okay you got to have a tight stop
you get stopped out on on a trade it's
not the end of the world there's going
to be trades get stopped out on
um Swiss franc
is you know again is also a nice Market
people say you know there's not enough
volume on the Swiss franc well there is
I mean look at these moves here
if you could pick up something happening
on the order flow here
oh really what's your risk
um 112 10 and a half down two just on
the other side here four four and a half
three even
all right same thing here right you
catch these very big moves this again
this is a 30 second chart not
everybody's going to be interested on a
30 second chart but if you're on a one
minute chart
um let's go back to a one minute chart
right this moves here now
again this was Friday you know this
Friday even though it was it was month
end it was one of those weird Fridays
where it's like month then you sort of
got this holiday the day before you had
some better movements
um now
let's take a look at bonds for a second
here okay
this bonds is also
a nice Market to trade uh okay why isn't
this working here
on ZB
here we go now on the default settings
okay now there's a couple of adjustments
you could make on on the settings and
now you know bonds is a good Market too
explain it on so this was bonds
yesterday okay now obviously 7 30 the
the data come out but then you know
later in the day you had you know a
trade here that would stop you out of
trade here that the market kept pushing
up into new highs and and going higher
now
let's take a look at the settings here
because bonds is a market that
if you were to look at a footprint
for the bonds just pull up a quick
footprint chart here in the bonds real
quick and let me explain something
because really you know what the
indicator does what the combo does is it
takes this information off of a
footprint chart okay and bonds you know
these slower moving markets like bonds
you get a lot of this right where it's
just you know two price levels the bid
and the offer is trading bid and offer
maybe it goes bid and offered higher
doesn't trade anything or it goes
um you know offered lower but doesn't
trade anything on the bin it's just
basically trading the bid in the offer a
bit in the offer for you know for
quite a while and you know even
sometimes it's just you know trades one
price level but uh
all this information here can be used on
it so when this Market is trading in a
very
sideways honestly sideways activity but
very constrained you know it's basically
just trading the bid in the offer
um you're probably going to want to make
some adjustments because something like
the the
POC and and the value areas it's going
to be distorted because if you got
literally a bar that trades one price
level
or maybe two price levels well
your PLC is going to be that one price
level you only traded one price level
where you trade you know one price level
then one take higher
then
basically that one level is going to be
where all the volume is so
there's a couple things you could do one
you could turn off the PLC filter and
value filter okay now you're going to
get a few more signals but again if
you see here it's coming in
right is it more signals more signals
well there's signals if because the
problem is right like I said if it's
basically trading two price levels all
right here you can see 126 16 126 17.
one of these two is going to be your
price level
or your POC level right it's like here
right it trades two contracts at one
price level at the other
it's just 126.10
you understand that so it's by disabling
the POC filter now again you could still
use the
value filter but again it's
got to realize right when you're sort of
looking at these value areas and you
know similar to the POC
in a sense where it's just one price
level
because if you're looking at the value
area of a bar
right like here this green bar right in
the middle
54 90 and 16. well majority of your
volume is going to be right here anyway
so that's going to be your value area
anyway that's going to be your point of
control right the whole value area is
not going to be that because that'll be
all the volume and spreading out over
bars as well is going to sort of give
you that same
um
you know that same effect
in the sense that it's kind of distorted
so you could disable both of those so
you can see this is with the
POC
disabled but the value on but again it's
basically going to give you the same
sort of signal now
one thing that you can do right if
you're just using supply and demand
filters you could ramp up the momentum
strength a bit here to six which would
be the highest
uh you could even choose to change the
supply and demand strength a little bit
but
that's up to you in in the market that
you're going to trade now you're going
to get a few more signals right but it's
gonna you're gonna see here
right it's going to keep you basically
on the right side of the market most of
the time I mean you may get stopped out
here but then it's giving you the signal
down here to catch these moves up here
Ultra bonds also a great Market
uh to trade in again a trades similar to
the way
30 years trade I mean Ultra bonds is
basically the new 30-year Bond right
that's why they created the ultra bonds
is because the coupon is more on the 30
year now people will some people might
say that that's too many signals for me
okay well you're not trading necessarily
every signal unless you're an add-on
Trader right you're going to be trading
the first one if you take this trade get
stopped out then you catch the nice move
here and you catch you know the bigger
move there
um
another way to approach it
is POC filters value filter on and
supply and demand filter off okay you
know people see white do you want to
turn off this supply and demand filter
is partially because the way the market
moves you know again Ultra bonds and
bonds
the way it's trading is just basically
one or two price levels sometimes and
if you're taking off the supply and
demand filter now you relying more on
the market moving away from value
because it's it's I'll be honest it's
sometimes it's hard for people to
understand how the market is starting to
move away
with fresh supply and demand because it
doesn't look like it's moving at all
right I mean look at this it's basically
going sideways
right so picking that up really what
you're looking for now you're relying
more on the shift of
um the market itself moving away from
you know the balance area rather than
looking for Supply coming in or demand
coming in and you can see here right
this is with the
supply and demand filter turned off as
opposed to again this is what
momentum strength set to six but
if I have supply and demand I'll change
that back to four really quick but again
this is how the defaults look on the
ultra bonds okay see one signal here
nothing happening because of the trade
entry signal if I had the trade entry
signal disabled on this Market
again that's maybe something you might
want to do simply because this Market
moves slower
right where it goes a little bit
sideways over a little bit longer period
of time if I had the supply and sorry
the trade entry signal disabled see the
signals here signal more signals coming
in
but for this
for now I'll just keep it enabled okay
so again this is how it looks with the
default settings
okay
signal here nothing showing up here here
because of the trade entry signal okay
again on slower markets you might want
to disable it but if I were to take off
supply and demand
now it's basing its
decisions is based in its entries off of
the price action you know the market
moving away from the
um you know the established balance
areas and
you know a market that's
perplexes Traders a lot
is net gas
and again net gas is something that not
everybody is going to be interested in
trading but
you know I always
have like a benchmark of you know how
does the order flow look on a market
like
um net gas which a lot of Traders
struggle okay and you can see again
Friday so a little bit tough
but
again this is with uh this is the same
setting that I was using on Ultra bonds
okay
I mean it gets some signals here yeah
nothing special going on there in the
morning there's a nice cell here but the
day before
right nice moves up moves down moves
back up
um
you know this big monster move the other
day down a little move up here
again you know net gas is not something
that you'd want to do but Nat gas again
is is a market that I think
um you could use sort of the same
settings that you would use on say
um bonds or Ultra bonds you know supply
and demand filter off
okay and again if you want to since you
have the spline demand filter off maybe
you want to ramp up the momentum
strength a bit higher to something like
six
and you can just sort of see how the you
know slight differences come in here
okay
now again if I were to disable the trade
entry signal
because again it's set pretty tight
um you know now you're going to see
basically whenever those that
combination of settings takes place
right
so it's a little bit uh
more signals catching it on the on those
moves now
let's go back to bonds really quick here
uh
let's do this to me
no I'm just able to type it in ZB today
it's acting all funky on me
all right so let's go back here to the
bonds all right so this is bonds trade
entry signal turned off now
again if you want to use trade entry
signal it's up to you I I personally I'm
going to pass on trades that don't have
that follow-through order flow
just because I know that without that
follow through order flow
only gets into bad trades it just helps
me personally keep me out of bad trades
again usually the default I use on a lot
of indicators is two and two
but
on the combo I got it set pretty quick
at one and one if it was two and two you
can see here
right it's not giving me this one here
it's not giving me this here this is
with it on but I'm still you know
capturing some decent moves you know
this one here maybe it will stop you out
here
um you know similar move here in the
morning so
let's take a look at you know es a lot
of Traders
today
uh yes here
okay let's give it a second here yeah
it's got a lot of data so it takes you
know with trade with the tick replay
enabled it does take some time I'll get
to your questions uh shortly here
actually I want to get through what I
want to talk about these markets
let me just grab a drink of water here
okay so this is es yesterday
you can sort of see these signals here
right even from way earlier
um because you know basically it's been
bullish the whole day
um yesterday now again this is that
setting again this is one minute chart
with the spine demand filter turned off
it's with the momentum strength set to
six if I were to have it set to
four
right and supply and demand
enabled is going to be a few less
signals
okay see up here it says still
calculating right up here and then
that's just because my charts I tend to
load a lot of data
um
on there so again you can see
from four in the morning there was a Buy
Signal here
you get no actual signals here here
there's one here right ahead of the cash
open
um then later in the day right as you're
coming out of this little bit of a
balance area on the 75 area all the way
up into these new highs now
again you could play around with it
right if you don't want to use the
supply and demand filter
just disable it see how it looks on your
chart
okay now
in
I'm going to talk about mnq because you
know markets like M and Q
it
mnq is kind of its NQ mnq or
have their own unique idiosyncrasies to
those markets okay because
well let me just put it on here really
quick
um
it's a little easier to explain showing
you now
NQ M and Q you tend to get the bars you
know that are very wide right I mean
you're talking some of these bars again
you know 15 283
all the way up to Newt 99 it's 15 points
you know there's days I mean we know if
you've been around the markets long
enough you know where you're getting 50
point bars in in a minute even
less than a minute
you know we're in 30 seconds you can see
a 30 point bar it's just it's insane so
some of these settings
since those bars are are
kind of wide
let's go into the settings
okay so if I was going to use this POC
filter I'd probably turn off okay supply
and demand filter Well for now let's
keep it off and I'll just store it I'd
stick with value just to start with
[Music]
um
again it's it's one of these things
where it's just
based off of that market it's just
because the Market's kind of volatile
you know honestly if you're an mnq
Trader
um you know I don't want to say that
yeah don't get this indicator but you'd
have to play around with the settings a
bit more
um just because of the volatility in the
market so this is just using the value
filter okay and again setting it at one
which is it's its lowest okay
I mean you're getting signals but again
remember this is a volatile Market you
know a short here from 13
you know all the way down to the 80s
right then you get some Longs up here
obviously you know before the number
you're not going to trade the number
this is the cash open here but once the
cash settles down you know some nice
movements up you'd actually get in my
opinion with with a market that's as
volatile as this you can actually trade
this in the night session you know
you're getting nice movements that
aren't off the Richter Scale you know
like this is a move from say 130 150 up
to you know this is 150 here you know a
20-point move whereas during the day
this whole move would be one bar
okay again that was Friday how did it
look on you know the day before again
you see this is the problem with a
market like NQ is you talk in a bar from
120 all the way down to
65. it's just a bar like this right so
you know
even though you just just starting to
kick off some bearish order flow in here
you can see what that zone being drawn
out
you get that very wide bar which just
sort of screws everything up in my
opinion that's why I say you know these
other markets currencies
um bonds
is something that you can you can trade
a lot easier a lot less stressful
but you know you can catch a move like
this it's fine you catch a move like
that that's fine but again you know
there's plenty of other markets out
there to trade
um you know even if since we're sticking
with stock indices let's go to uh
minidao ym
okay so what are the settings here I
think it's just supply and demand
there's a value filter
okay now
again sometimes you know I suggest to
people if you're just using one filter
ramp up the momentum strength as high as
you could go which is six
okay and you know maybe you want to up
the the value strength from one to three
if you're just using one filter
sometimes using the sort of the
strongest setting is going to give you
you know something a little bit more to
lean on you know
so or where's Cash open here right here
a little short here you get some Longs
here short this catches the offside then
you catch the rest of the day 580 you
know all the way up to 680 there it was
a nice move there
um again if you can
that's with value set the three
sort of the ym on the spectrum of stock
indices ym comes in between es and and Q
now if you're just going to use
spine demand filter
okay you could try that maybe you just
want to you know just use that set it up
to three
which is sort of the highest again
anytime you're just using one filter
maybe you want to set it on the highest
you know you're going to get a lot of
signals of course
but it's up to you that's just with
supply and demand filter
um
you know sometimes when you're looking
at the evening session
you know where markets are a bit slower
you know people say oh you can't trade
the night session it's not enough
information well there is
I mean this was last night at eight
o'clock on that last night but Thursday
night at
uh you know 8 P.M
right at 9 00 PM move down
at 11 PM here right and people say well
that's just one day I mean this was
Thursday's day session here
but again if you were to look back
the night before Wednesday night
okay 8pm now again if you're trading
stock indices during the evening time if
I say evening I'm in Chicago evening the
Asia day do it during Japan hours that's
the most liquid time but I mean look I
mean so that's basically from around 8
P.M this is 8 P.M here
at 9 00 p.m look at that it's a decent
move from you know worst case scenario
160 all the way down to lows here at 140
down to new lows down to new lows
um
yeah so I'm going to take a look at some
questions here I'm sure there's uh
some questions
let me uh see here
okay
yeah the Abe s is they're going to be
recording yes there is going to be
recording I'll send it out later
um
today and you know one of the things
that I'm I'm working on is I'm going to
try to put together a little
guide I'm always hesitant to put
together Guides of settings because then
people automatically think that oh these
are the settings I have to use
because this is what Mike says no I mean
it's up to you to use that or maybe you
want to adjust it to something that
suits your style of trading a bit more
um again sometimes I put out settings
and people think it's written in stone
that you know it's like the Ten
Commandments I have to do this no you
could use it however you like but I'll
probably work on that this weekend Abba
asks Abe asks uh does it work on ES and
qm yes I mean I just showed you those
um
blessing asks for those of us that have
software they assume you mean uh word
post Trader software well actually the
price that we have it at now you know
usually when I release a new indicator
it goes out to everyone that has their
software first and it goes out at a
reduced price
um because you know we're selling it now
after
you know in a few days after the holiday
I guess we'll be resetting it at a
higher price
um do I need to subscribe to order flow
package with ninja no you can just you
could run this as long as you have
you don't okay basically you know
ninjatrader's got two versions of their
software they've got the free version
the paid version
when you buy the paid version
it basically it just unlocks a few extra
features
um some of them are
the order flow their order flow package
the cumulative Delta which is this
basically like a Delta candle the market
depth map
um the trade detector which I believe
others bubbles the volume profile
um and their their v-wap tool as well as
their
uh volumetric chart right which is the
you can find it in here right volumetric
is their footprint now
this combo is designed to run on
a normal bar chart so basically it's
taking everything that you would see
here on a footprint
and it's distilling it into the signals
that you're seeing here so that you you
can use it with a footprint or the
volumetric if that's how you trade
that's how I trade
but if you don't use a footprint chart
if you don't want to use a footprint
jump you don't want to go through that
analysis that's why we have this
indicator
created so it takes all the information
that's taking place here
and distills it into simple signals on a
bar chart or a Candlestick chart and
people don't really use bars they use
candles nowadays but um yeah you don't
need that all you but
if you know one of the other major
differences I believe on on the paid
version versus the free version of
ninjatrader is the use of
ATMs right automatic trade management
right so like you get long or short in
the market and
it will put in your your buy stop and
your take profit or your cell stop and
your take profit the free version you
can still trade on it but just doesn't
have that feature as well which
[Music]
um
in my opinion is something that helps
out a lot of Traders is having an ATM
but it will run on the free version it
will run
as long as you have a real-time data
feed you do not need level two data you
just need the normal data feed and
again if you have an account with a
broker ninjatrader brokerage or wherever
you can get a discounted data fee there
I've got CME cbot 9x call Max urx
they've even got level two on all those
but my monthly data fees are about 65 or
something like that 66 if you were to go
out and get a third-party data feed
um you're gonna be paying a lot more
right just the CME alone for real-time
data feed is like 118 keeps going up
it's a big money maker for these
exchanges so
you just need a data feed
ninjatrader you're the paid version of
the free version I know traders that are
using this they're trade markets
that they can't access through
ninjatrader okay and they just use this
as their charting software you know
people that trade Forex will follow the
CME currencies
look for the signals and they'll execute
in the Forex Market on a different
platform so yes
um it will run on any version of
software
Jared asks uh
okay Jared yeah
um
you're
asks about the different charts that
it'll work on yeah I mean you know
it does work on things like hikanashi
charts
now you know when you get into things
like wrinkle charts
like the the native default rankle chart
on ninjatrader doesn't use tick replay
so it's not going to work on there but
there are other wrinkle charts available
that you can use
that are out there for free I think the
indicator store has one Pablo has one
that runs with uh take a replay again
this is uh
what am I looking at here mini Dao
but uh let's go back to Euro currencies
really quick
High kanashi chart
again this is you know this is the
hikanashi chart with
well that's not the default settings but
it's the just the supply and demand
filters with POC turned off and
momentum strength turned on all the way
value filters turned off
right on a hikanashi chart on on Friday
um it does work with markers I've tested
it I've made a video for people it's up
there and uh
Bloodhound I have a user uh shout out to
Bob that tested it with Bloodhound and
says it works with Bloodhound I don't
use Bloodhound myself
um hang on here Henry I see your
question
let's make a note here
uh
okay Henry yeah I'll get that sorted out
um he's just asking about a license from
uh earlier on his workflows Trader
uh a basketball trade room no
um I don't
have a trade room anymore
I don't know there's in the back of my
mind I'd love to get one started up
again but uh it just comes down to
timing and you know trying to make it
where
you know the most people can get the
most out of it
um Eric s tested versus untested Okay so
foreign
is these zones until tested
and fixed
okay it's not tested in until and tested
or until it has just tested or fixed and
what that means is let's find one here
Okay so
you see the zone is being drawn out here
okay and it stops
once the market gets through the other
side if it's a Zone where it just sort
of comes back and touches it like this
bar did here and then went back up
it would still draw it out I mean
obviously later it traded through it but
it will stop when it gets to that area
right now you see there's these signals
where there's no Zone because the next
bar itself came in and tested the Zone
immediately
but me personally I like to use the
zones because there's going to be times
where you just have these zones that are
just left out like this it just helps me
identify that hey you know what we're in
a strong Trend up then obviously if I
got this Zone from this bullish Zone
that's been going up for quite a while
and all of a sudden comes down and blows
right through it
okay obviously I well you should be able
to identify that things are changing
anyway but it blows right through it
chances are it's going to go much lower
another way I like to use the zones is
like here you got a short signal and the
market reverses training above it okay
why the Zone here it's telling me this
this Zone down here at the bottom let me
just move this chart up
there's bearish information here here
here but we're trading above it so
obviously there was some sort of shift
in the order flow
and you know if anything I should be
looking for Longs right I'm not going to
sit here and say oh I got this short
here I'm gonna you know the Zone I gotta
get short because sometimes you gotta
change your thinking okay I had the
short Zone but we're trading on the
other side of it what is the market
telling me
okay that's how I use zones
um do I have a template with settings
that you're not showing and you just
start out the defaults the default
settings
is your base okay that that's why when
we release the indicator I'm very
specific on my programmer on how I want
the settings set
so it's not like everything turned off
and you gotta turn it on and figure out
which comp that is your base setting the
default settings okay then you could
sort of take it apart like do I need the
POC filter or do I want to use the value
filter or this or what about the
momentum strength the default is is in a
sense the template that you're going to
start with
um he asked yeah I showed that uh es and
and mes
for the most part the same but uh
let me put mes on here
um kalpesh asks does this work on
one hour time frame or higher well
honestly I don't trade out over a one
hour time frame or higher with order
flow
um
simply because
you know order flow is best taken
advantage of
as soon as you're starting to see
something you know develop that's why
again I started out this presentation I
did show you on a 30 second chart but
again not everybody that's that's a
little too fast for a lot of Traders
that's why I show people on on a one
minute chart but
you know once you start going out an
hour or two
you know even 30 minutes for me is quite
long it really diminishes some of the
things that you're starting to see now
this is the mes chart from Friday
yesterday again this is the hikingashi
chart
um quite nice actually but let me just
put it on a normal
minute chart
um let's give it a second to come up
here
okay again what well let's go back to
the default settings here
okay so as a 30 second chart I need a
one minute chart but um right combo all
right so I'm adding it here so this is
the default settings this is a 30 second
chart let me go back to a minute chart
some water here
okay so this is the default on Friday
right not much going on here some
signals obviously early
during the European session or four in
the morning Chicago time
not saying that yeah you would have
bought it here and held it all the way
up to here but
this is uh again this is a one minute
chart maybe you want to make an
adjustment
um
put this up here
if you were to you know you could figure
out
you know because again
one minute chart on mes
well I'll start out with this POC and
value is going to be kind of similar
actually on a mini chart let's put it on
the just the supply and demand filter
sort of looking for these shifts in
supply and demand so it says calculating
up here because it's got to go through
all the tick data I think I've got like
three days loaded on here this is how it
looks on the mes on a one minute chart
um you know maybe you want to
yeah
make the supply and demand filter a bit
stronger go to three
momentum strength you want to make
stronger since you just use leaning on
one aspect of it
um you know you change that to six this
is how you would go through you know
your own Market yourself
if you wanna see sort of which is the
best setting again I'm using the trade
entry signal so it's just
I'm really just focusing on the
triangles here right so it cleans it up
a bit more
okay
uh
uh there's no email there's this
question is are there Audible and email
alerts
there's no email alert but uh in the
setting there is a sound alert here
right and in the user guide It's
explained on how to set to enable it you
just click enable but um
go back here
right sound alert enable you just check
it there then you just sort of go
through right there should be one
already set up in there
then
you know if you want to change it you'd
go into your PC go into the program
files itself under your windows Drive
go to ninjatrader 8 sort of sounds and
you can change it to whatever you want
or you know add your own in there
um
Simon asks there's a big difference
between this combo and Market flow
Trader well
Market flow Trader deals with the ratios
this one doesn't so let's just sort of
put it on here
I'll take off the swing filter
oh that's Market exhaustion
um Market flow Trader
thank you
enable these here
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
change the colors though
so you can see sort of
the differences I'll change this to cyan
cyan the red so I'll change to
yeah I wish that they had
an orange they don't really have an
orange their orange looks like
weird color this is orange red but uh
I'll change it to magenta cyano magenta
for Market flow Trader so I'm curious
how
these look side by side I've tested
combo with a lot of indicators
I always want to make sure that there's
not a lot of overlapping
um
on there
okay
so let's make sure I don't have the
swing filter momentum is set to three
okay this one
trade entry is set to two so slightly
different actually see you're getting
conflicting signal here along here along
here this one came a little bit after
this one came a little bit before
you got some buys here there was a cell
this is the
uh
the cyan and magenta is the market flow
Trader you got one sort of stuck in
there here so slightly different signals
but again it's
reads different things in the order flow
so here it's given a bunch of signals
but it's not giving
um
anything on the combo this is the market
flow Trader here
right here is sort of mixed in
here you had a couple here this is right
before the number you get it right after
the number
your bullish signal so again yeah
signals they're based off of completely
different things in the order flow
Market flow Trader sort of analyzes
again uh so I got the combo set at uh
just supply and demand filter so it's
kind of a
Niche down
but microflow Trader sort of reads
what's happening on the edges of the
candles combo
is more of what's Happening inside the
candle like in in the heart of the
candle so to speak
uh let's go through some more questions
here
um
Mark asked how many monitors do you have
up running this package using tick data
well
okay because the second part of your
question is does it slow down your
machine it doesn't slow down my machine
um
I've got a lot of charts like I don't
know if you could see it here but I mean
even underneath this I got all these
tabs open and I've got two other
monitors here with a bunch of charts on
it
what it's running in real time there's
no I don't have anything like this is my
trading PC as well
um I didn't have it on my testing piece
this is an i7 this PC I'll show you an
I9 my other testing PC is an i5 and I
got a data feed going in there with
about 40 tabs open it's although that
that one
I also use for a lot of other things as
well this one is just for trading I I
have no slowness in my PCS I do turn off
um
sort of make it a little bit easier for
me yeah I the thing that I hate the most
about these new versions of windows
and then Microsoft is that OneDrive I I
go in and I I just I shut it down
um I go in the task manager and shut it
down because that one it does cause some
issues that that one drive I hate that
um
thing because that will put
you know you see my CPU usage right now
is at 21 with the OneDrive open it puts
it up around 40 that alone could be like
20 percent but um
man I'm not a tech guy in that sense of
you know monitoring all that stuff but
OneDrive if you have it enabled I would
disable it it'll speed things up a bit
more but again I've got this PC he's got
you know all my PCS minimum of two
monitors my trading PC's got three
monitors
um
you know just
really quick you know just to show you
you know like this is the other one
right I've got you know a bunch of these
other screens going on there and then
even on my third monitor up here right I
got my chart board up here behind I got
my footprint up here Market's closed so
there's nothing going on there but this
is three monitor system here
um Robert S this is like an advanced
Delta scalper but more advanced
Robert this doesn't deal with Delta at
all
um so it's completely different than the
delta scalper
uh blessing asks uh
yeah blessing because lessons asked
about the the special rate
again you know whenever we release
something new we like to give people you
know the action taker so to speak yeah
at a bit of a discount right and and you
guys know that whenever I release
something after the release period which
usually lasts for about a week
that we increase the price okay
um
yeah Henry I I saw your question I I
addressed that let me get off this
webinar first and take a look for your
emails
um
because I'm not sure if it's in my spam
fold or not
um Antonio asks uh
I don't know how it would work on penny
stocks honestly
um
I'm curious Antonio
uh
you sent me a couple charts on on your
penny stocks I don't trade stocks little
penny stocks and I'm always curious on
how it would work
um in other markets I'm always
fascinated by that
um bless you know you don't need an
additional data feed whatever data feed
you got it will work on okay
um where I asked I spent a lot of time
on bonds does that mean indicator is
working better on bonds than Futures
like es and Q well I mean this is es
it's
it comes down to the markets that you
like to trade me personally I just find
markets like bonds and
currencies
follow order flow better in my opinion
than markets like es or mes or NQ
um you know NQ is sometimes you're
trading in queue you feel like by you
know just for a couple hours at the end
of the session you're like I felt like
you're in a wrestling match with the
markets
um I just find you know markets that
move a little bit slower maybe I'm just
getting I'm an old fart or something but
you know markets that tend to move
directionally are easier to trade you
know I don't need a market to have this
big up down you know a pullback from the
high you know here is 87 and a half all
the way down to 74.
twice before making that move
you know a lot of times in the bonds the
markets are just more flowing no pun
intended but you know just move nicely I
just find it it's easier to read the
order flow and it's not to say you know
again this is mes you know there's a lot
of nice signals here this was yesterday
that you can take advantage of
again it comes down to what you want to
trade I know not everybody trades es and
mnq this is the thing that bothers me
the most is that I see people never
traded before
come to the markets start trading NQ or
mnq
they don't last very long because they
don't understand that that market is not
the volatility that you see in that
market is not what you see across all
markets okay it's it's just one of those
things where
it's it's Unique to itself and if you're
not familiar with it you just sort of
jump into it it's different
so that's why I do spend time on on
other markets other than NQ
um and Es because I know a lot of
Traders
they've gone through you know they've
been training for a while they started
out with es or NQ and then
they've been hit in the head with the
two by four it feels like until they
find a different Market that's more
suitable to them but again you could use
this on yes and Q I just find it
sometimes a little bit easier to show
how something works on you know a slower
Market
um
yes this is an add-on Robin she asks uh
she owns aft it's uh not considered an
upgrade
it's an add-on indicator like Delta
surge it is uh it is an add-on basically
it's
reading the order flow for you
and then putting it on the chart
where you should buy or sell
um
Thomas asks uh where's the question here
Thomas not related to the combo
okay it's not related to the combo but
this question is uh possible to build a
strategy on strategy with the order full
of signals like value area by
um
possibly and if you're using a footprint
chart possibly
okay rajes
um please discuss how you use your trade
setup that you on the first side PLC
value areas and two others not through
settings but by looking at the order
flow okay
well it's really quick
um let me just
see if I got let me just clean up this
footprint chart really quick here
there's a lot of things going on and you
know let's turn off a lot of these
settings uh
let me show this
I can use that then prints I'll turn off
value areas
find a balance summer contents make sure
that I don't have too much going on
that's going to confuse you
um
I'll turn it off I'm going to put
controls
okay so basically this is your your
normal footprint got the value areas
obviously he's got imbalances and you
got your point of control
so you know what it's going to look for
areas where the one the market is kind
of balancing a bit
over I'll say a certain period but it
takes that into account then it's
looking for areas that was up at a high
you know if demand sorry your supply is
coming in right so it's going to look at
the volumes on the offer side
um
it's going to look at you know how the
volume is forming in the bar right like
is it appearing somewhere near that high
is being distributed evenly or is it
appearing somewhere near the bottom
and you know from that it's going to
give you your signals again it's it's
not
something that oh okay you got this
check you got that check you got this
check
you buy because there's a little bit
more to it right like
you know you
but I don't want to go into the exact
algorithm of it you know or use that
term algorithm but the exact coding of
it but it's taking into account the
imbalances where they're coming in right
how the value area is relative to
previous value areas where's the point
of control coming in relative to
previous point of controls coming in how
is the price action trading after that
right so if if for example here right
you've got this area sort of balancing
you got the imbalances you got this
other imbalance right next bar is going
up okay and he's going to generate a
signal for you but it's looking at those
individual things
and it's putting it on your chart for
yourself for you
so that you don't have to sit there and
say ah you know does does this point of
control matter or does this value area
matter not only that but relative to the
previous bars
okay
um is it Nelson asks is it good for cl
well let's pull up CL here
uh
again I'll just go back to the default
settings really quick
oh okay well this is the settings that I
was using on yes you can see there's a
lot of signals um
when you're just using spine demand
filter okay now let's go back to default
load it up here
and so these are default settings
calculating
okay so Friday
nothing off that default setting on
Friday again that's just the default
setting the day before
Thursday a nice cell here doesn't look
like much you know but maybe you're it's
coming on this bar here so if you're
getting short
well this is the bar you'll be getting
short on right here
so
69.90 is down here down
well
drop from 69.90 right down here or
Consolidated around the 50s then dropped
another 50 cents here there's a move
here again this is just with the default
setting
um day before and Friday there was
nothing the day before I'm not saying
that you could have bought it here held
it all the way up folds back down to the
level then shoots up
um you know two bucks but again this is
just the default setting
than the day before here
it's a short here so it came back up
tested and then sold off
um we've been here late in the day on
this was the 27th right getting short
from around 68 20 68 15.
down below 6700
if you know again you could adjust the
settings how you want there was nothing
really happening on Friday
but um
if you're going to adjust the settings I
don't know maybe start taking off
PLC filter or value right you're going
to get a lot more signals
okay maybe that's too much maybe put
them back on or maybe you want to try it
without the supply and demand filter
okay so this would be just the POC and
and the values yeah
you don't want to be getting along here
here here
again it really depends on what sort of
settings you want to use you know
in Friday
the other day
the day before sort of similar trades
here you got a few more cells
there's one here you'll buy there that
was the day before
29th
again on the uh what is that 28th you
know that Buy Signal there still same
one
and the day before again similar signals
so you know crude
I'd play around with it a little bit
find uh
sort of the optimal setting you know
maybe I'd use this and
the value
this is value filter spine demand filter
turn off the trade entry signal
or maybe set it a little bit
you know sort of
two and two
you know a little bit better
that's what the POC filter turned off
you know it's one thing to set a setting
for one particular day say oh you know
this is nice and then usually you still
got to test it with you know other days
right
this is four in the morning but U.S
session that moved down moved back up
you know with just the default settings
it had this short here and it had this
short here didn't have this move back up
or this move here
[Music]
28th
a little back and forth here
in this one and just pulled back enough
to stop you out
so
day before it's nice moves up here nice
moves down so again it really depends on
the market and what you want to set it
and Robin asked I thought there was an
upgrade coming in June which was adding
momentum to off indicator
um we are are working on an upgrade for
the order flows Trader it's not June um
usually we release them because the
summer time is the time where
we work on all this upgrade we're going
to be up hopefully we're going to
upgrade the off uh should be out by
fourth quarter
of this year
that will have a few more features but
that's the order flows Trader
um blessing um I don't know if it'll
work with robot Labs I doubt it because
robot Labs is from Ninja caters and it's
kind of uh closed in the sense of uh
their own indicators on that
um Antonio it's been fairly accurate
that's good to hear on
you should send me some charts Antonio
so I could I'd love to uh sort of build
out
some of that stuff on stocks
um helmet asked
is accomplished no it's not part of the
combo is not part of order flows Trader
six package it's a standalone indicator
um
Baba says uh the combo is the best of
your indicators and I've seen and most
of them yeah Bob it's uh
it's
we're quite pleased with it again is uh
when I how to say it uh
it's just one of those things where I've
never for some reason I didn't dawn on
me to
code it up for a while but um yeah
excuse me and Bob is the one that
touched these with Bloodhound as well
guys now Maria asked how does this
compared to Delta scalper side by side
um
I don't know let's pull it up again this
one doesn't deal with Delta at all so
it's one of those where I'm kind of
curious to see
ah at least I should change the colors
that's a Delta scalper here right there
but uh
just change the colors on Delta scalper
just so it's showing
different
things here so cyan magenta for Delta
scalper
again I'll just stay on the crude
Delta scalper gave a buy here
gives themselves a cell here right
before that but again it's
you know completely different analysis
of the order flow
but there was a cell here on Delta
scalper
nothing on uh no cell around there on
the combo so again it just reads
different uh different things in the
order flow
less than this yeah it's grains and
bonds are so much easier to follow for
you since you're not itchy Twitchy
squirrel and do not drink coffee yeah
it's uh you know grains grains we just
had that wasde report I believe
yesterday but uh
my opinion I love grains grains are a
great Market to trade well obviously
just really quick yeah the report come
out
on Friday so big move up in the grains
Delta scalper
obviously picked up
signal because of the increase in Delta
but this is not a normal movement in in
grains but this was the combo coming up
here
um right after that big move or the day
before
you know combo nice move down okay you
get stopped out here this is right after
the open
back and forth but then a nice move
again you know people that iron grains I
don't trade greens but grains right this
is a soy meal grains it's ten dollars a
tick
so I'll move from 394 and a half down to
393 is a hundred dollars 394 and a half
down to 390 and a half this is a 400
move
um Ernie asked can we switch
shorterfields kind of different PCS if
we move license key yep
um
if you know anytime you change your
machine
tell me and uh
switch over your license we'll just
create a new license token Ernie
um
is there a discount with multiple order
license yeah I usually
offer a discount for additional licenses
because I know some people got two PCS
like me I got a traveling PC and I got
you know my desktop PC and
um you know you travel you want to
follow the markets trade sometimes it's
uh you need another PC and yeah we
usually I haven't set the page but it's
usually about 50 off
um on the additional license
um Thomas asks uh
the convaluators and ratios be combined
in the indicator no they can't
um
and uh do we have an indicator like that
not at the moment not at the moment
um we don't have something like that
uh in the past you mentioned
you know actually let me just go back to
your other question we do have the value
scalper
which deals a lot with value areas
and
again this is
let's change these colors magenta and
whoops that's going to be magenta it's
going to be cyan
um value scalper deals with value areas
here
that might be a good that would be
something that we could actually add
ratios to
like you know you catch that move there
um you know some of these moves going up
but um yeah at the moment uh not
um
ranged okay so a question that came up
about range based charts so let me just
uh clean up this a bit here
the last question because we've been
going on for about an hour and a half I
don't want to keep you guys uh on all
morning
but uh let's just change it back to the
defaults okay and go back to the bonds
and on the four range charts
okay so this is the defaults on the four
range now
of course any day you get a big Trend
day like this you know you want to be on
the trend I mean that was nice Friday
he had
you know most of the night on Friday
you know from the reopen
until 4 30 was you know until the number
came I was here then you got the big
movement the day before it's just a nice
move down and that's what the defaults
with the uh market like the bonds
um you know there's a couple ways to
trade it either nope
you can take out the poc in value
if you wanted
um I don't know how it's going to look
it's a little bit more movements here so
again a few more signals again it's
still you know the whole day is down for
the most part it's just that one bullish
signal here
one bullish signal there
another way to do it
bonds
disable supply and demand and have the
POC filters on POC values on
right again
all right here on Friday
getting a few movements up
um
yeah anyway guys you know I'm gonna wrap
things up here it's
we do have that special
price right now 279
um it's going to be up there for at
least probably until
after the Fourth of July the fifth or
something because again and I know still
there's a lot of people traveling or you
know it supports the July weekend right
you're supposed to chill out and relax
SO trading markets is not necessarily on
everybody's Focus but again just go to
orderflows.com combo here I'll just pull
up the URL
but you know he said when we increase
the price it's going to go up probably
to it goes 379 or 397 right just look
here right you can see the charts
um and just go right through there 279
for now
so
anyway guys
um thanks for taking the time out uh
this morning
and
again you know you could get it and and
you you find something interesting by
all means you know feel free to share it
yeah just one other thing something I've
been working on right now it's just it's
taking up a lot of my extra time is I'm
trying to build like this community
thing
and you know for order flows for all all
you guys
that
you can go in you can post your charts
you can share it with with other because
I know a lot of you guys want to connect
with other Traders because you know
people that trade greens want to you
know talk to other people that trade
grains or you know people that trade
bonds want to talk with other you know
and share their charts Etc I'm hoping to
get that up going in in the next few
weeks it's it's it sounds it sounds easy
building this community I know people
have like discords and telegrams and uh
problem is that is
it's easy to get lost in those things in
the sense of um you know people that
trade
grains aren't going to be interested in
these other markets so it's going to
give like certain sections you know
people that use just order flow or
people that use this indicator can post
in and things like that so
um
I'll keep you guys posted on that
hopefully in the next couple weeks
that'll be completed so have a great
rest of your weekend guys and I'll catch
you guys later bye bye